On social media, I heard someone discuss the need for extra caution in the bathroom when
flushing.
Flush three times and clean the toilet after ever use.
When you've had chemo, so others don't get sick from the chemical, the chemotherapy itself
if they're spread of it.
Do you think that is a concern?
Well, it is a concern.
You have a lot of toxic chemicals in you doing chemotherapy.
You don't, you do want to be careful, you know, you could, it could make someone else not
feel good.
They're not going to get enough of it to cause ill health, I wouldn't be so concerned
about that.
But if you had little children around, yeah, you'd want to be more cleanly than that.
I have never really addressed this subject because I thought that you would have gotten information
from the oncologist about things like this.
So I've never really investigated more than, I think I've had a couple people ask this question
before, but we'd never really posted anything on it.